chiamati slitte rio ammann ha ha si no
non ci ho cliccato il tasto per altro in
un'altra pagina che madonna che occhiaie
ma che cazzo
ha forse perché non ho dormito un cazzo
vabbè ci stava per tutti ragazzi e
prevenute avessero video sono fa vj
pedaggi siamo tornati su slitte rio dopo
che ho fatto il video sulla modi di sly
per io ne avete tutti quanti detto che è
uscita una nuova skin che sarebbe questa
qui bella non ho ben capito il perché di
questa cosa che può tra l'altro che non
so se avete notato perché la trota non
l'ho fatto notare passano to2 video di
fila che arrivò primo e cioè non è per
dire perché si affermi di più di bike ma
veramente ormai credo veramente ragazzi
di aver trovato la partita perfetta c'è
che poi io faccio gaga di mio
ma come mai curati si mutò dicendo che
credo che l'insieme di todi è morto
qualcuno lo stupido
beh va beh va beh quel che frontale vai
vai vai vai perfetto è morto un altro
molto un altro fermi nativo ragazzi sono
volendo tutti che cazzo faccia ma cos'ha
fatto fermi che non so capi niente che
cazzo succede
oddio è morto perfetto non ho capito io
ho rischiato di morire sei volte prova a
far che cazzo è quanta gente morta in un
solo punto vado ai titoli di la canzone
perché va bene quanto casinò oggi perché
aveva basta quanta gente morta in questo
episodio basta troppi un genocidio
beh va beh io no ragazzi non sto capendo
niente quanta gente stiamo ammazzando in
un secondo è assurdo lo so quanto sono
quattordicesimo ho fatto un miliardo e
mezzo di punti dei suoi morti tutti
grazie al pene un po incisivo un po si
sono uccisi oro fantastico stanno
dicendo che era
e allora non riesco a dire un cazzo oggi
[ __ ] tua madre ma in curatissimo
per la prima volta ammetto che è stata
bella prima di fare questa bellissima
figura di merda ragazzi stavo dicendo
che l'insieme di tattiche che sto usando
io vabbè quanto culo se le volte molto
contorto anche tu no fun cuore ok ok va
bene quanta gente
niente regali st episodio muoiono tutti
non si capisce perché stavo dice mi fate
finire la frase gesù l'insieme di
tattiche cose che ho usato fino ad oggi
per giocare all'inter io alla fine credo
sia l'insieme giusto era un problema
tutti mi avevate cazzo ok con il
rilascio credo che sia veramente
l'insieme è giusto di tattiche perché
finora ho quasi sempre raggiunto buoni
risultati quindi chi cazzo fa questo è
ubriachi simo è scemo vabbè ma dopo ci
siamo mai vero c'è una ragione la cena
c'erano circa 100 di mantenimento
timento team ea tutti i miei di vita gli
arti
ok anche questi 7.000 o ragazzo tornato
come prima anzi forse anche un po più
grosso di prima ok ok ma da quanti punti
o pre occhiaie e decimo in un secondo
ragazzi quindi la mia teoria sulle mie
fatti che funziona direi che sono giuste
quanta ansia questo qua si sta
ingrossando sto tizio io in gruppo lui
scommettete vado
questa è vabbè quanto sei scemo eh tutti
scemi oggi questa ragazza è una cosa che
dovete ricordarvi tutti quando qualcuno
prova ad inglobare qualcun altro diventa
più piccolo per forza di cose perché si
restringe e allora provate a inglobarlo
voi che viene benissimo quale devono in
curato questo qua questo è lunghissimo
però facendo il cerchio come lo sto
facendo io in questo momento ti
restringi per forza di cose calore
approfittatene voi per inglobare lui
dovete solo stare attenti che qualcuno
adesso non inglobi voi ma per il resto
funziona
ecco tipo quello [ __ ] non aspettato
quasi però che cazzo mariano in culo non
ci crea mica per un attimo spo sperato è
che vorresti farlo brutto [ __ ] non
te lo permetto fatti i cazzi tuoi
e morto il karma allora quello che morda
e vabbè sono morti tutti sono primo
adesso no non ci credo non ci credo non
ci credo non ci credo non ci voglio
credere porca put ho cliccato il tasto
branco in un'altra pagina che è che i
nervi quando succede questa cosa non ci
posso credere sia aperta un'altra pagina
bella l'iva ragazzi non ci voglio crema
perché vive su una barca miglioto ogni
volta ma ce la farò mai oa morire
normalmente porca vacca laida non muoio
mai normalmente deve sempre succedere
qualcosa di un fulmine che mi si spegne
il computer o mi saprà una pagina ma non
muoio mai normalmente non c'è verso
antonio pratica va va bene va bene calmi
però pon è uno quello che vuole fotter i
punti perché la gente vuole fottermi
punti
non l'ho fatto no quello sì c'è sempre
stamattina mi si apre è ben che tripla
come gli in gruppetti male tutti quanti
e niente ragazzi agiva così è oggi va
così così bene che non so che cosa dire
tu diresti se la manovra va messo in
curando tutti quanti cioè non c'e oggi
proprio non c'e verso guardali mamma mia
che partita hai visto registrando ste
cose non ci crede nessuno quando le
facce com liz litterio ammann ha rally a
furia di fare il figo che l'opinione lka
branzi ma do quello a quanto incassato
senti zio se fai così incazzato ci penso
è infatti più che perfetto ci siamo
ragazzi stanziare che salvataggio
ragazzi il casinò no
cos'ha sbagliato direzione sono andato
dalla parte sbagliata come un deficiente
così a caldo ha detto l'agente scema
sentite ma è va bene ma basta a venirmi
addosso
meglio così epiche schiacciate voi non è
un problema reale non mi conviene non mi
conviene però lo faccio sesso su
campione del mondo di slater il record
mondiale di uccisioni sluyter io in una
sola partita
eccole corto buon titano
quanti punti ho preso devo cercare di
chiudere questo deficiente vai vai vai
vai perfetto quanto stupido ma cosa ho
fatto regala creazione quanti punti
mi sa che sono vii vii by così il primo
sa quanto cazzo sa il primo 82.000 il
primo sta 82 quarto ma vuole scemo ma
volevo tutto drogato o come fai stare a
83 mila punti
un cazzo faccia non ci arrivo ma spero
che crepi
o come carico io primo stava non posso
arrivare 82 mila punti magari fa 82.000
pur non si capisce se sono io se lui il
campione del mondo di slitte ri oggi
secondo me io ci arrivo anche secondo il
problema arrivare primo
veramente arrivare primo stavolta la
vedo poi uno grosso così non dovrebbe
essere tipo in tutta la mappa amica non
è esageratamente grande che killer sto
per fare vi prego ditemi che riescono
perché c'è questo fedrica gare il pene
ce l'ho fatta ciao ragazzi come state
adesso il globo per bene tranquilli
tranquilli ci sono io che vi tengo al
caldo farà quello che pensa ancora
uccidere gli altri ma amico mio sei
morto che cazzo mai
mica pista non ci credo se m'ammazza
così se mi ammazzava così mi metteva a
ridere che amber sei una tipa pure
minchia mi spiace amber sarai
sicuramente un'americana probabilmente
anche [ __ ] mai non posso farci niente se
sei caduta nella mia trappola
e così che rimorchio io tizia tiziano
ferro è il vincitore per il 9 più figo
di slither io da quando ci gioco è lui
tiziano ferro che è morto vabbè mi
spiace tiziano non volete ma perché ti
sei chiamato tiziano ferro o secondo
ragazzi sono secondo come avevo predetto
adesso l'obiettivo è arrivare primi solo
che primo c'è uno che ha 81 mila punti
secondo me i ragazzi che poi tratto non
ne fa più di 81mila rimasto lì secondo
me è un tizio che è arrivato a 80 mila
punti e non si fa tutto il perimetro
della mappa senza cagare nessuno e
continua a girare così tutto il giorno
attorno alla mappa perché vuole essere
prima vuole farci figure pensate che
vita piena che c'è quella persona lì che
sta intorno alla mappa girare per essere
prima a una vita che proprio non riesco
a invidiarlo
ma dopo quanto rischiato ma non è
riuscito a uccidere ma da quanti punti
tutti i miei ho deciso affetto sono miei
ragazzi l'ho preso le ci siamo ragazzi
20 o raga forse riesco a battere il mio
record e non sono primo rendetevi conto
col mio record non arrivano anche a
essere primo 24.000 23.500 questo credo
sia il record per adesso mio saprò vivo
che è buio del culo rega pensavo di
morire male non sono morto quanti ne
uccisi sta partita questo sì è prima che
inglobi me frate mica devi passarci una
vita ti sto 27.000 o regga il mio record
e va bene ti vogliono globe armi non ce
la faranno mai perché sono troppo grosso
30.000 punti lega sì sì sì sì sì sì sì
sì sì faticati tu hai ucciso io da che
33 mila ragazzi o sto facendo un
punteggio pazzesco e il mio record
assoluto della vita e non sono primo è
incredibile vabbè ragazzi io non c'è
33.600 ma siamo scemi ma non lo
raggiungerò mai più nella vita io credo
di aver fatto la più bella partita su
slitte rio della storia per quanto
riguarda me che non ho mai fatto un
punteggio così alto di slitte rio e non
ho mai ammazzato così tante persone sui
liberi quindi io sono pienamente
soddisfatto di quello che ho fatto
tranne perché minchione che cara
affanculo rimane prima ora grazie al
pene un tipo che rimane a girare attorno
alla mappa per rimanere il primo avrà
una vita sessuale molto attiva dai
ragazzi concludo che l'episodio spero
che video vi sia piaciuto e cosa sento
più stesso argomento è un mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook come nei video
trattare iscrizioni sono gestiti 16v il
diavolo prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]